salut il ya quelques temps la fin de
l'homme mais spectacle c'était un
valence quelqu'un allait si une boîte
pour moi cette boîte apparemment avait
une histoire puisqu'elle était
accompagnée d'une lettre un peu lourde
avaient quelque chose à l'intérieur et
je suppose des instructions je ne sais
qu'une chose c'est qu'il a fallu 127
heures pour créer cette boîte et je vais
essayer de résoudre l'énigme avec vous
en face de vous
[Musique]
une sorte de tige en bois avec les
chiffres d'un dea de ce côté là et le 1
et le zinc est au bout du coup on a tous
repérés qui avait pu juste ici et quand
je mets mon doigt je vois que qu'il ya
comme un ressort que je peut l'enfoncer
mais la chaîne au maximum je suis
dégoûté ya des travaux en ce moment le
met vraiment j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont en train de percer chez moi quoi
veuillez nous excuser pour la gêne
occasionnée
de ce côté là une roue ça ça tourne ça
tourne un peu dans le vide mais ça
tourne
là c'est pareil on sent qu'à une
résistance je découvre donc ce qu'il ya
dedans alors dedans il ya un parchemin
quand le temps fut venu ils partirent
pour les quatre coins de la terre
lorsqu'ils découvrirent le premier monde
il revint sur leurs pattes compter le
nombre de grains de sable que le sablier
avait laissé filer il sur un sirh
combien de temps il leur faudrait pour
faire le tour du monde c'est à l'heure
précise à 45 mille deux cent trente huit
secondes près qu'il repart chez eux
j'espère que xavier ne m'a pas trop
surestimé tous trois étaient très
heureux de leur voyage et l'aîné très
fier de son calcul toutefois le plus
jeune fille remarquer que si l'on
pouvait voir le bec du phénix à pâques
les compteurs seront remis à zéro avec
un petit bout déchiré ici la terre pour
moi c'est l'objet c'est le coffre
lorsqu'ils découvrirent le premier monde
il revint sur leurs pas compter le
nombre de grains de sable que le sable
il y avait laissé filer ont peut-être
faire faire tourner la boîte en entier
et la refaire tourner après en entier
dans l'autre sens
45 1938 second set 153 minutes soit 12
heures parce que je me dis que s'il ya
autant de secondes c'est qu'il faut
réduire pour trouver un truc mans on
trouve ça un 12,56 6 11 11
alors 2,56 ça par contre ça me parle ça
me parle parce que ces deux fois tôt et
si vous avez regardé la vidéo que
j'avais fait le jour du pid et c'est à
dire le 14 mars
j'avais parlé de thau tossée 6,28 et
6,28 fois deux ça fait 12,56 mais comme
tous ces deux fois puis c'est à dire que
ce serait quatre fois puis et là ça
commence à me parler parce que pis on
l'a ici
alors je sais pas trop ce que j'ai fait
là mais j'ai entendu une comme biya
l'intérieur et donc j'ai commencé à
tourner je suis revenu en arrière comme
dans l'histoire il ya ait marqué
lorsqu'ils découvrirent le premier monde
il revint sur leurs pas donc je suis
revenu et après j'ai juste fait un tour
entier en fait en me disant en fait ça
symbolise peut-être un tour du monde
complètement alors je sais pas si c'est
ça aussi gpt quelque chose mais à la fin
il ya sakip est sortie complètement est
par contre si je l'enfoncer que je le
tourne je vois qu'il ya quelque chose là
qui se passe juste au dessus
il ya deux espèces de languettes kislev
comme ça je ne comprends cette énigme
mais en tout cas j'ai retiré de
baguettes je les mette avec les deux
géants d'avoir une idée depuis tout à
l'heure j'essaie de faire entrer salade
dans sa marche pas du tout et et là je
me dirai ça ressemble un peu à une clé
ça a l'air d'être un petit peu une clé
donc j'essaie en le filmant directement
avec vous mais ça n'a pas l'air d'être
sommes je crois que non pourtant c'était
une punk east je viens de trouver un
nouveau trou et je sais que cette phrase
est très étrange dit comme ça quand
quand je tourne ça en fait ici un
nouveau trou juste là donc je le tente
mais je le tente bien proche de la
caméra parce que si c'est ça ça marche
pas mal
[Musique]
oh oui oh ça vient d'éjecter tout le cul
de la boîte en fait c'est actionne un
système de ressorts qui maintenait la
boîte passé un truc de ouf à l'intérieur
ce qu'il a fait le mec qui pour moi j'ai
pas fini
j'ai ouvert la boîte mais là je vois
bien qu'ils aient une boîte dans la
boîte ok en fait de deux juges neutres
et bêtes
il suffisait de décaler un petit peu
l'ensemble pour ressortir cette voie de
la boîte à à xavier je suppose que tu
regarde la vidéo
sache que je connais très très bien ces
boîtes là et ce qui m'a mis la puce à
l'oreille c'est le fait que tu fais tout
un entourage ici en général on fait un
entourage pour cacher des jointures
en fait ces boîtes elles souffrent comme
ça et c'est très très malin mais du coup
je connaissais ça c'est très malin parce
que ça s'est cachée par la jointure là
et ici est le seul moyen en fait
d'ouvrir le tiroir c'est d'avoir les
deux doit placer au bon endroit
c'est à dire qu'en faisant comme ça
comme ça même comme ça ça fonctionne pas
c'est juste comme ça que ça fonctionne
regardez ça fait tout est là thuy est
presque soit curieux oda n'a rien à part
tout court magica j'arrive tissavel
cours magica de roberval objets
présentés dans une de mes bibliothèque
donc enfin on a xc iv en clair x et ça
c'est 90 je crois et 4 et sa c4 ses 94
la carte bancaire vous présenter un jeu
de cartes ordinaire vous y chercher une
carte de trèfle et vous extrait celle-ci
de celle ci une pièce de monnaie bien
que vous demain été montrées vide
auparavant je suis pas sûr que ce soit
sur la bonne piste mais alors du coup je
sais pas pourquoi il y aurait le les
cours magique
bon c'est énorme il vient de tenter en
fait je tourne plein de choses depuis
tout à l'heure avec le livre ça donnait
pas trop est tous assez ça
et en fait je vois là comme je me dis
que le mec les geeks et qu'il a fait ça
aussi j'ai essayé de taper tout ce que
j'avais sur la boîte en comme une
adresse internet
donc il y avait 94 ans 1 en deux il y
avait 23 ans 3 c'est 235 et en 4 c'est
si vous voulez essayer ses 94 pour 23
points de 135 points 209 du coup il ya
toute une animation qui a commencé à se
mettre en cours là je met ici pour que
vous voyez et là j'ai bien vu que ça
ressemblait un petit peu un cerveau donc
je sais que je suis au bon endroit
je sais que c'est ça ouais c'est le
cerveau que j'utilise souvent bien sûr
sur la fiche mon spectacle et c'est un
mortel c'est un cerveau en 3d regardez
c'est une constellation en fait en
réalité
trop bien je suis bluffé je suis
vraiment bluffé maintenant j'ai un petit
mot qui m'a envoyé sur un autre mail que
j'ai imprimé et que je dois lire qu'à la
fin de la vidéo
mais en résumé j'ai créé une chasse au
trésor avec un vrai trésor enterré
depuis maintenant un peu plus d'un an
quelque part en france
je connaissais ce principe j'avais fait
une vidéo là dessus pour une maison
d'édition qui a fait un concept un peu
similaire à la chouette d'or en fait
depuis la chouette d'or ceux qui savent
savent ce que la chouette d'or et en une
semaine j'ai donc dessiné la boîte
inventé un système de clé séquentiel et
construit la bouffe est non mais c'est
un travail
ça dépasse mon entendement je suis pas
hyper bricoleurs en plus cette histoire
est contée dans un livre les neuf
énigmes de la clé du temps se livre à
paraître permettra d'accéder aux neuf
énigmes et de tenter de les résoudre
afin d'accéder à la position du kof qui
existe vraiment et qui contient 33
lingotins d'or de 50 grammes ce qui fait
à l'heure où j'écris ces lignes 61 1377
36 euros en fait je vois bien ce qui est
en train de se passer je suis pas fou
non plus c'est un espèce de placer une
produit sans que je sache que c'était un
placement de produits au départ
alors je sais que tu as parlé il n'y a
pas très longtemps d'une autre chasse au
trésor c'est ce que je disais j'ai bien
conscience également que tout ça peut
être considéré comme du placement de
produit c'est ce que je veux dire
et tout ça est très délicat mais non
c'est pas délicate a bien fait et bien
écoutez ça va partir dans un petit lien
dans les commentaires si je trouve un
bien quelque part parce qu'il n'y a
aucun lien vers ton livre mon cher
xavier a fallu plus de 40 minutes 42
minutes et 26 secondes pour faire
l'ensemble de cette vidéo
d23 information importante c'est que
j'avais annoncé un live pour la pour ce
dimanche 16 comme c'est pas que vous
avez été nombreux à me dire ah bah non
en fait c'est gênant alors je le ferai
le 23 je sais que c'est les élections au
23 mai c'est pas grave on va se faire ça
le 23 à 17h30 walla le 23 avril à 17h30
je compte sur vous notez le quelque part
la deuxième chose c'est que je suis
toujours en spectacle vous avez toutes
les dates de tournée dans la description
la semaine prochaine par exemple je suis
à mulhouse et la dernière date sera à
nantes le 30 juin
y'a pas de d'énigmes supplémentaire dans
cette vidéo là ou alors c'est vraiment
qu'il ya une image de quelque part de pi
qui traînent dans cette vidéo et que le
timing exact d'apparition de pifou
donnera encore une fois un temps d'avant
ce pour gagner ce que vous savez dont je
parlais dans cette vidéo là encore une
fois il s'agit simplement pour vous
d'avoir de la vence le jour vous sortira
la vidéo denning pour gagner ce de ce
donjon
va pas prononcer le nom si vous êtes
encore mal ce tas de la vidéo laisser un
petit pouce en l'air pour me le dire
parce que ça me fait plaisir ça veut
dire que tout ça ça vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner dans la
dernière vidéo il y avait les résultats
d'expériences mental de à très bientôt
cha